well happy Sabbath everyone happy
Sabbath we want to thank you Elder SK
for joining us again for one more
segment I know that uh God has blessed
us through you here thus far and um
before we go any further and we attempt
to ask you some of these questions would
you be willing to have an opening prayer
for us our Father in heaven we thank you
so much we can come to you freely in the
name of Jesus Christ I ask you now day
God remember the promise of James 1:5
if any of you lack wisdom let him ask of
God grant me that wisdom and Pastor that
we may answer these questions to your
satisfaction and to the blessing of your
people in Jesus name we pray amen amen
so as we were looking through some of
these there's everything from uh Last
Day Events to relationships and so uh I
can't say they'll be in any order
but here we go it's the first question
is uh what more events are still to come
to pass before the second coming of
Jesus well there's several events that
have yet to come to pass one is the
Sunday law one is the close of probation
we have no date for that the other is
the seven last plagues another one is
the little time of trouble there's the
time of Jacob's trouble all these things
have to come to pass before Jesus comes
and so they're quite a few but don't
wait until you see them in order to make
yourself right with God
because you may pass away tonight God
forbid but we cannot wait until tomorrow
or the day after today tonight now as
you sit where you sit is the time to
connect with God in such a way that if
you close your eyes in death the next
time you open them you'll see him as a
savior not as a judge but again the
things that still have to happen the
Sunday law the little time of trouble
the time of Jacob's trouble the uh the
um the sever last plagues of course will
occur after probation has closed and so
all of these things still have to
happen thank you so much uh here's and
of course my add the cancellation of
religious freedom in the United States
that has to happen the cancellation of
religious freedom and the establishment
of an image to the beast in the United
States thank you and the next question
is this is I think from someone who was
um convicted from last night uh how do
how to start how may how can I continue
to build a character and maintain it
that is Honorable to God in Christ
object lessons page 100 paragraph 1 ELO
white writes the scriptures are the
great agency in the transformation of
character Jesus prayed sanctify them
through thy truth Thy word is truth
also in that prayer Jesus said in John
17:1 15 I pray not that thou should take
them out of the world but that thou sh
keep them from the
evil Jesus prayed to the father and
asked the father to keep you and me from
the evil in this world having said that
to the father then Jesus tells the
father how to do it in verse 17 s ify
them through thy truth Thy word is truth
in the same prayer Jesus goes on to say
regarding himself verse 19 and for their
sakes I sanctify myself and so he
Sanctified himself through the truth
this is the method whereby we can grow
in the character of Jesus Christ outside
of the word there's no power to do that
amen this person asks how can we know if
we are with God or with Satan by the
fruits you shall know them very simple
by the fruits you shall know them the
indwelling of Christ produces the Life
of Christ in speech Behavior everything
else the indwelling of Satan produces
the works of Satan now sometimes the
works of Satan can look like the works
of Christ so we need to have discernment
but we are told by the fruits you shall
know them and so you may know that you
are of Christ simply by your attitude
towards God's
law do you obey God if the answer is yes
there's Christ within you do I disobey
God then Christ is not the ruling power
nor do I make a mistake from time to
time is Disobedience My Lifestyle if the
answerers yes then Christ is not the
ruling power in the life I am not saying
he has abandoned you completely because
once he does that your probation has
closed but surely he is not the
controlling Force the evidence that he
is is your and my Conformity with his
law Amen in other words obedience is
proof of the indwelling of Jesus
Christ there was a few of these uh
questions so we just kind of narrowed it
down to one and this person is asking um
tips on memorizing scripture
and doing daily devotions any any right
memorizing scripture well for me is
simply a matter of constant practice in
mind character and personality Volume 2
page 601 paragraph 4 El white writes
that which at first seems Difficult by
constant repetition grows easy and right
thoughts and actions become habitual
that which at first seems Difficult by
constant repetition grows easy and so my
Approach is constant repetition constant
repetition we call that practice makes
perfect El also says putting bible
verses to music is an effective way to
memorize the Bible I don't do that but
it works for some people you may write
verses down and by physically involving
yourself in that process you Aid
retention of the verse in other words
you're involved physically you involved
mentally and so writing it down on 3x5
carrying them with you looking at them
from time to time excellent way but my
simple method is look at it understand
it look away look again and then anchor
it in the head but I think the key is
discipline you must there are four D's I
recommend first D
desire you it's difficult to stop
someone from doing something that he or
she really wants to do good or bad and
so when they were building the tower of
B
God said behold the people is one and
they have all one language and this they
begin to do and now nothing will be
restrained from them which they have
imagined to do only God could have
stopped them they were so
determined you look at the seven last
plagues plague number any of the seven
plagues even though the people are
suffering they still blaspheming God
because they are at that point
determined not to honor God now you
reverse that you look at Daniel the
three Hebrew boys they were determined
to honor God even in the face of death
mhm how determined do you have a desire
to do it that's number one desire number
two
discipline discipline simply means if
it's raining I do it if there's an
earthquake I do it if I'm dead I do it
nothing gets in the way of doing it you
remember the old Nike saying what was
it that's
discipline that is what is taught in the
Army you don't go to war and say well I
don't feel like shooting have an upset
stomach no no no no regardless of how
many bombs are bursting and bullets are
whizzing past your head you have to be
there to defend your country and so
there's desire there's discipline there
is determination
I am not giving up if it takes me 6
months to memorize John
11:35 I will take 6 months and that
verse simply says Jesus wept and so you
have
determination and for those of you who
watch football when the running back has
the ball and there five guys holding on
to him where is he headed for that go
line they're hitting him he drags them
he is he just wants to cross the the
plane that's all
touchdown that's where we must be and
the fourth D is divine help ask God to
bless your efforts and he will do that
because by trying to memorize you'll be
doing something he wants you to do Thy
word have I hid in my heart that I might
not sin against
him thank you so much this next next
question by the way let me throw this in
sorry sorry when I go to the gym I've
said you've probably heard me say that
on some YouTube
Sermon if I do a set of bench presses
when I get off the machine instead of
just sitting there
doing I recite a
passage in that minute of recuperation I
recite I may take a passage like
Revelation 15 just eight verses say
twice then go another S I may pick one
verse and say it for my entire one
passage for the entire workout if I'm
doing l pull down
I do a set when I'm finished Psalm 126
Psalm 110 whatever I just do it so that
I use the time
wisely I'm said that I said that to say
this people say I don't have the time
you can find the time how long does it
take to take a shower 5 minutes you have
five minutes to
recite is this microphone working amen
you have five minutes how long does it
take to brush your teeth a minute and a
half you you can recite
something I'm not joking I am
serious how long does it take you to
eat if you're not talking to someone you
recite something while you're
eating how long does it take to walk
from dormatory to this Sanctuary recite
something when you go to bed at night do
you fall asleep immediately no while
you're lying in the dark recite until
you fall asleep
so that the last thing on your mind is
the word of God to protect you from the
devil who attacks you at
night let me tell you something about
the word of God and his power to protect
you night or day but particularly night
I was in a certain country preaching a
young lady came to me she said uh I am
bothered by Spirits at night they come
they bother me they molest me all these
thing she said I haven't slept in
weeks I give her 1 John 3:8 he that
commited sin is of the devil for the
devil sinth from the beginning for this
purpose the Son of God was manifested
that he might destroy the works of the
devil I told her confess all known sins
before sleeping take this verse say it
say it think about it for this purpose
the Son of God was manifested that he
might destroy the works of the devil I
say say that fall asleep saying
it she came to me the next
day she said I slept for the first time
in
months this in your head is power
against Satan let me add something else
without
preaching all created beings were made
by the word of
God angels were made by the word of God
Lucifer was made by the word of God he's
now Satan the thing that made him must
be greater than he
is are you with me this made
Satan this has more power than he has
this is what he's scared of not on the
Shelf but in
here this and so Jesus said in Matthew
8:16 or the Bible says of Jesus and when
the even was come they brought unto him
all that were possessed with devils and
he cast out the spirits how with his
word what did Jesus normally say to
demon-possessed people or to the Spirit
come out that's the word and what did
the demons do they came out okay
amen this person asks um how can I
practically detach myself from
Amusements of this world some of these
amusements might not even be bad in
themselves but they're still distracting
me from God they don't have to be they
may appear not bad in themselves but
anything that takes you from God is is
not good or
anyone that takes you from God is not
good I go back to the word of God I will
always take you to the simple word of
God to detach yourself from the
attractions the allurements of the world
expose yourself to the word it is the
counteracting
agent study this read it dwell upon it
it will change change your
mind it really will and El says our
minds take the shape of the things we
feed
it or the shape of the Constitution or
the nature feed your mind with this and
your desire for the things of the world
will fade
mysteriously fade this and add to this
the writings of Ellen White
did anybody say amen
amen as a young person messages to young
people as a young person letters to
young
lovers and generally steps to Christ
read chapter 5 first then read the whole
book amen uh this question says the
Bible is clear about being slothful and
lazy
how can I become the opposite of that I
know where you're going with this to the
Bible yes Ecclesiastes 9 verse 5 verse
10 whatsoever thy hand findeth to do who
can finish the verse do it with thy
might the answer to laziness is
work you ask God change my
mindset and give me a hardworking
mind
whatsoever th hand findest to do you are
morally required to do it
well what's that key word morally
laziness is immorality in in action if I
can put it like that a lazy person is
behaving
immorally immorality is more than thou
shalt not commit adultery th shalt not
kill all Ten Commandments are moral
Commandments Sabbath breaking is
immorality are you looking at me or past
me Sabbath breaking is immoral
Behavior honor thy father thy mother by
the way your father and your mother
include the older members of the
church 1 Timothy
5:1 against an El rebuke not an elder
but ENT treat him as a father and the
Elder women as mothers the younger men
men as brothers and the women as
sisters so the Bible says what did Jesus
say who is my mother who is my father
who are my brothers those who obey
me the Elder members of the
church our father and mother
spiritually honor thy father and thy
mother disrespect to them is immoral
Behavior fornication is not the only Act
of immorality people can perform at any
age whether you're youth or not but
you're all young I'm talking to you
disrespect for Authority is immoral
behavior all right uh this person asks
how can I overcome the sinful desire of
lust okay where am I
going back to the Bible yes the 10th
commandment says th Thou shalt not
covet lust is a desire for something
that should not belonging for the
conquest the of this the answer listen
to Christ object lessons page 100
paragraph 1 if studied and
obeyed the word of God works in the
heart subduing every Unholy attribute
what did Jesus pray sanctify them
sanctification is the act of removing
spiritual impurities from the life Jesus
tells the father do it through
this in John 15 in speaking to his
disciples Jesus tells them now you're
clean through the word which I have
spoken unto you Paul to the Church of
Ephesus Ephesians 5: 25 and 26 husbands
love your wives even as Christ also
loved the church and gave himself for it
that he might sanctify and cleanse it
with the washing of Water by the
word there is no way to finagle your way
around the
word for every spiritual crisis the
word even God himself has magnified his
word above his name the greatest proof
that Christ was who he said he was
weren't the Miracles he performed but
that he fulfilled every Old Testament
prophecy about
Christ the word the greatest evidence of
God's presence is his word not a miracle
because Satan can perform Miracles but
Satan cannot produce
truth start the solution to your
problems with the word of God studied
and obeyed the the power is released in
obedience amen uh you already answered
the first part of this question so I'll
modify it a little bit this person has a
sees the truth and knows it's important
they feel that their heart is out of
harmony with it and they do not uh see a
purpose for their life um how can you
help or give guidance on someone finding
their purpose the purpose the purpose
the person sees no purpose for life it
seems as though sees the truth they
seize the truth but it says therefore
they um they say every moment is uh
fleeting whether it's good or bad and um
they're just see they don't they don't
understand their purpose for their life
okay everyone has a purpose for Life
Genesis 1:26 states that purpose let us
make man in our image but there's
something else that person can do listen
carefully if you feel no conviction ask
God to place the conviction on your
heart ask him to do it the very first
prise of the Bible is Genesis 3:15 and I
will put enmity between thee and the
woman ask God to put within you a hatred
for all that is unlike Christ if you do
not feel the conviction ask God because
your carnal nature will never produce a
conviction to do
right because the flesh is All Flesh let
me say it again the listen to the carnal
nature adultery fornication uncleanness
lasciviousness Idol Adry witchcraft
hatred variance emulations wrath Strife
seditions heresies envyings murders
drunkenness Rings Galatians 5:19-21 not
one good thing in that
list your carnal nature will never
convict you to obey
God you need input from outside of
yourself and that's Christ The Life of
Christ for those of you who do physics
you know this law is the third of first
I don't recall an object in motion or at
rest tends to remain in motion or at
rest unless acted upon by an external an
unbalanced force in other words objects
do not like to change the inertia so if
that chair is sitting still it will stay
still unless an outside force changes
its inertia because the chair has no
power in itself to change its
inertia so if you roll a ball through
the universe
it will roll and never stop unless
something stops
it a sinner will sin unless an external
force
intervenes that external force is
Jesus are you with me amen and so if
there's no conviction ask him because
your nature will never Supply a
conviction to do
right when you disobey and disrespect
your elders it did not come from the
spirit of
God is the spirit of
Christ El actually says when your child
is going through a tantrum rebuke the
evil spirit in that
child because the Holy Spirit does not
work like that and so again I keep
harping on it if you're not convicted
even though you see it intellectually
you're not touched by it ask God what
did David pray and say Psalm
51:10 create in me a clean heart oh God
he can't do it renew right Spirit he
cannot do it why does God write the law
on our heart because we cannot write it
worse than that we don't want to write
it God has to ask him to place a
conviction on your heart regarding the
truth you intellectually see but you're
not committed
to amen uh the next question is how do
you know when a dream is from God if it
is consistent with the word of God if
you have a dream that tells you go kill
somebody that's not from God are you
following me there are people who say I
hear voices I saw this I saw that and I
went and I killed all my family members
that's not from God the word of God is
the ultimate
test of
anything if you have a conviction from
the spirit and is contrary to God's word
is from the wrong spirit so if you're
receiving dreams and the dreams do not
conflict with word word of God then
there's some certainty the dream is from
God but if one iota of that dream one
microscopic sliver goes contrary to
God's word it is not from God the the
test must be the word of God generally
and the law specifically test everything
by the word at large and the law
particularly all right uh this next
question I think this person understands
the state of the Dead And for those that
um choose to disobey God will be um
eventually destroyed this is what they
say what is the point of striving for
perfection in Christ and going to heaven
if I can live a fun sinful life and not
burn in hell forever since according to
the Bible we return back to dust ceasing
to exist forever how is how is uh since
there's no Eternal punishment in regards
to um being torment for all of eternity
um um and it says um can't really read
this writing here but it says um
basically why why choose Christ if I can
just have have fun here on this Earth
okay there's no Eternal punishment the
person says there is no Eternal
punishing but there's an eternal
punishment you don't burn forever but
you're wiped out forever are you
following me that's Eternal now that's
one the other side is eternal life with
no sin no sickness no disease no war no
whatever living with God face to face
traveling the universe with angels
that's the other option and you're
telling me why strive for
that then what spirit is driving
you God offers you life you prefer
death God offers you blessings you
prefer
curses and the person said why can't I
have fun now well you have to Define fun
the way God defines
fun in heaven fun is consistent with the
word of God on the earth fun is
consisted with the words of Satan you
see Heaven and Hell have two different
dictionaries what do you mean by Fun
smoking dope you know committing
fornication staying out loud getting
drunk is that fun
no converted mind calls that
fun that is design of Destruction are
you following me that's not fun and so
if you're willing to sacrifice a life
without end of blessings in the very
presence of God you can travel through
space visit other planets where people
never sin there's no sickness no disease
you look into the face of the angel
Gabriel you look into the face of God
you hang out with gab with with Abraham
you talk with
Noah you want to miss
that just to
smoke you need to say
psychiatrist next again ask God to put
in you a desire for the things he
loves let me tell you something on the
day when Christ comes you'll be glad you
made that
choice I read in El white some place she
said the reason why God delays his
judgments upon us and the final
destruction of the world is because he
knows it will be so
terrible the Bible says it is a fearful
thing to fall into the hand of the
Living God Hebrews 10:3 it's a fearful
thing when this loving God has had
enough and he has to
destroy it will be
terrible ask him to give you a this
for the life to
come thank you uh this person asks what
is your favorite Ellen White book and
what is your favorite Bible verse my
favorite ELO white book I believe is
steps to
Christ it's very non-denominational
it's a powerful
book I always recommend it to anyone who
wants to sample her writings or who
needs reassurance of God's love for that
person
steps to Christ and whenever I recommend
the book I gently suggest read chapter 5
first then read the rest of the book
steps to Christ a close second would be
the Desire of Ages but it's very
intimidating in his size but a
tremendous blessing steps of Christ is
small it's manageable but but I think of
a large El white book young people read
Harry Potter and it's twice the size and
it's not a problem for them so Desire of
Ages fine but seeps of Christ my
favorite Bible verse Genesis 1:1 in the
beginning God created the Heaven and the
Earth Let Me Tell You Why without
preaching a sermon look at the verse
let's pray again father as I continue
trying to answer questions give me a
fresh supply of wisdom in Jesus name I
pray amen listen to Genesis 1:1 in the
beginning God created what the Heaven
and the earth now we have God and we
have
creation do you see that in that verse
you sure
we have
God we have
creation creation is the result of God's
work God is not the result of
creation I'm not saying that clearly oh
you you're sleeping with your eyes open
let me say it again creation is the
result of God's work God is not the
result of creation are you following me
so we have God and we have
Creation in that verse now listen
again in the beginning God created the
Heaven and the Earth that's
everywhere when Jesus said all power is
given unto me in heaven and in Earth he
meant
everywhere and so God made everything
everywhere but here's God his
creation that verse tells me there are
only only two ways to
exist you're
either you're
either you're either God or you're part
of that's
it you either exist as God or you exist
as a part of
creation there isn't a third way to
exist and the principle that should
exist between God in creation is plain
and simple
dependence creation depends upon God for
its
maintenance by the way that is the
Sabbath
principle I depend on
God not God on
me and so in that one verse 10 small
words I see a lot
God
creation when a person Lucifer was tired
of being a part of
creation and so he said I will be like
the most
high if he had said I will be like a
lower Angel he would still have been
created am I confusing
you let me put it this way here's the
angel Gabriel here's an
amoeba if the amoeba becomes a bee is it
still
created is it still created yes if the
bee becomes a butterfly is it still
created if the butterfly becomes an
eagle the eagle an elephant the elephant
a blue whale and a blue whale becomes
Gabriel what hasn't changed they're all
created so essentially to change your
state the only option you have is to be
like God
that's what Lucifer
wanted all of that I see in Genesis 1:1
in the
beginning God created for him to create
he had to have been there before what he
created so I love that verse very
much the next question uh this person is
asking about your personal testimony and
how you came to know Christ oh very
simple I uh my I was a Catholic as a
little boy my mother found out about the
Sabbath she was immediately convicted
and struck and went in search of an
Adventist Church uh Sabbath keeping
church and found an Adventist Church a
friend of ours bless you was an
Adventist and we just went to a church
and the case was
closed I was a little boy had no choice
and I'm glad I had no choice I have no
date for when I individually gave my
life to Christ it just happened well no
not it didn't just happen but I have no
date no particular time there were no
Thunder claps no flashes of lightning no
nothing of the kind I just at an early
age decided this is true and I want to
follow it for the rest of my life so
it's not a spectacular story at all very
boring but uh that's
mine thank you the next question is what
does the Bible say about anger the Bible
has nothing well do you have your Bibles
with you yes go to Proverbs
16:32 Proverbs
16:32 what does the Bible say about
anger Proverbs
16:32 who wrote
Proverbs did he write all of them no who
wrote
Psalms did he write all of
them no okay do you have Proverbs
16 verse 32
someone who has my version read verse
32 yes right over
here stand up all right read nice and
Loud he who is slow to anger is better
than the mighty yes and he who
rules he who takes now they're talking
about the benefits of not expressing
anger unreasonable anger he that can
control his spirit is better than the
mighty or better than someone who takes
a city in other words
self-control is more powerful than
military
might now someone else read Proverbs 25:
28 raise your hand stand and read
Proverbs 25 verse 28 yes my dear brother
stand and read for us he that has no
rule over his own uhhuh is like a city
that is broken down can't control
himself loses control it's like a city
that's broken down and with Without
Walls now someone who has courage read
Ecclesiastes
7:9 stand up and read Ecclesiastes 7:9
we're talking about anger and when we
discuss anger we should discuss
self-control yes stand and read for
us
not yes
restom anger rest in the bosom of fools
unreasonable anger is the behavior of a
foolish person notice I said
unreasonable anger now here is what
Jesus had to say about anger go to
Matthew 7 let's read from verse 21 here
is Christ himself talking about anger he
very
frightening Matthew 7 reading from verse
21 who will read for us yes to my right
stand and read nice and
musically entom of but does the of
Father no no no sorry not Matthew 5
Matthew
5:21 I may I think I said
yes go on but
I uh-huh
yes keep going and whosoever shall
uhh keep
going good Jesus equates unreasonable
anger with
murder
mhm unreasonable anger with
murder that's Christ so when Christ
proclaimed from sin by the way it was
Christ who spoke the law he spoke it for
his father when he said Thou shalt not
kill it also included unreasonable
anger anger is a dangerous
thing or anger not now does God get
angry yes his anger is righteous ours
must be controlled by the spirit of God
now go to Ephesians chapter 4 read I
believe it is verse 25 Ephesians 4:25
who has that for
us yes
sister Ephesians
4:25 read
26 be angry and do not yes go on do not
go now anger is such a terrible thing
deal with it quickly thank you very much
God bless you don't let the sun set on
your anger don't let a day go by with
the anger unattended let not the sun go
down on your wrath because you may hurt
someone you'll surely hurt yourself and
so we're told be angry and don't sin in
other words the anger that's Justified
is Godly anger but much much anger is
unreasonable it can lead to
death and Christ equates it with murder
he also equates murder with
hatred and so if you you have an anger
problem memorize verses that deal with
anger and say them and say them and say
them Proverbs 16:32 Proverbs 25:28
Ecclesiastes 79 Ephesians
4:26 Matthew 5
21-23 thank you uh the next question is
do you think God created other perfect
beings on other worlds and we're just
the only rebellious ones the Bible gives
us a clue despite the very explicit
statements from Ela white that there are
worlds where people live who never sin
in Revelation 12:2 therefore Rejoice ye
heavens and ye that dwell in
them ye
Heavens he that dwell in them the Bible
frequently speaks about Heavens not just
Heaven
Heavens wo therefore Rejoice ye heavens
and ye that dwell in them the heaven we
have where God is that's where the
Angels Live then there's another part of
the heavens where unfallen worlds
exist people have never
sinned and they watch what's going on on
this
Earth they watch Ela tells us in uh
desire of AES page 758 paragraph 2 when
Jesus said it is finished the unfallen
worlds rejoiced because his death
covered them
yes there are other worlds where no one
sin the only place in this vast Universe
where rebellion occurred the only planet
is this
one and that's where Christ
came to do something about the Rebellion
to provide hope for those who will
accept him if we're faithful one day we
will see the inhabitants of unfallen
Worlds you must believe that
in One Vision Ela white was taken to one
of those worlds and she saw them and she
said how is it you're so beautiful
you're so magnificent they said strict
obedience to
God she told the angel with her please
let me
stay the angel said no you have a work
to do but if you're faithful one day
you'll mingle with them amen
go
to Zechariah Chapter
3 Zechariah
3 well no let's let's forget that that
it Tak another Direction it's okay next
question okay uh this person's asking do
you have any advice for student leaders
yes make this your manual
make this your Manual of operation as a
student leader there's a burden upon you
to set an
example in everything you do so Those
whom you lead will be properly led the
concept of people being led was invented
by
God the highest angel was Lucifer when
he fell Gabriel took his place the other
Angels listen to him Gabriel tells the
Angels what God wants Lucifer used to do
that and so we have this concept of one
leading the other the high priest was
the leader of all the Levites he was a
spiritual
leader the apostles the chief Apostle
was Peter you Le the Old Testament or
new testament you have Elders you have
deacons there are leaders people who
lead others follow but the leaders must
lead in harmony with the word of God so
if you're a student leader your priority
is to make sure that your influence is a
saving influence it is a transforming
influence for
good all people exert influence you
can't stop it the only choice you have
is will it be good or it will it be bad
so if you're student leader let the
Bible be your guide your manual your how
to
book and of course read the book by El
white Christian leadership I think it's
called read that book
but God bless you for accepting a
position of leadership at a Blue
Mountain Academy it's good experience
for later life you've already touched on
memorization and also devotions this
person's asking what is a great method
for Bible
study I think I mentioned
earlier write it on
cards 3x5 cards write your verses two
put it to music sometimes when I preach
I asked who can recite the 6 or recite
the 66 verse uh books in order and some
people they have to do it to music in
order to do it music is one way there's
several Bible passages I recite to music
the prodical son Psalm 91 Psalm 50 Psalm
51 sorry um other passages Psalm 139 the
pieces of music I use and I recite so
whenever I drive my car I have the music
on I'm reciting um revelation 12 is also
I have some music I use to recite it
music is one way to Anchor the word in
your mind but my primary method
is
repetition repetition
repetition read it understand it then
get the words in order get the sense get
the substance get the theme get the
thrust get the meaning get the message
then make sure you have the words in
order
That's My Method constant constant
repetition if you try you'll get better
day by day you really will as in the
case of anything you do over and over
you get better and
better I think you covered this on
Friday night but repetition deepens
impression here it says is it possible
to achieve perfect Holiness here on
Earth through God's transforming power
is it possible to achieve perfect
Holiness all right go to 2 Corinthians 7
someone read for me verse
1 who has it 2 Corinthians chapter 7
read verse one nice and Loud having
therefore these yes stand and read for
us therefore prises yes let us
ourselves ah doing what perfecting
Holiness in the fear of God now note
let's let's add to that 2 Peter 1:4
let's go to 2 Peter 1 verse4 as we
discuss the possibility of perfecting
Holiness in this life second Peter
1:4 who has that yes my dear sisters
stand and read for us
whereby uhhuh
yes now
whereby these precious promises we may
be partakers of the divine nature having
escaped the corruption that is in the
world through lust through the word of
God obedience to it and study we are
brought to the place where we are
perfected by
Christ we become partakers of the div
divine
nature talk about perfect Holiness go to
Hebrews 12 someone read verse 10 of
Hebrews 12 Hebrews 12 verse 10 Hebrews
12 who has
that yes stand and read for us
please after the own uhhuh but
heet that we might partake
yes we are to be partakers of the
Holiness of God Hebrews 12:10 1 Peter
chap 1:4 we are to be partakers of the
divine
nature Now read Philippians chapter 2
verse
5 I'm sure you when you see it you
realize you already know
it Ephesian not Ephesians Philippians 2
verse 5 yes my dear sistant nice and
Loud was also yes let this mind be in
you which was also where in Christ Jesus
not a mind similar to
it the same mind Christ had on this
Earth we must have and so we've read
three verses one 1 Peter 1:4 we must be
partakers of the Divine nature second
one Hebrews 12:10 we must be partakers
of God's holiness three Philip uh
Philippians 2:5 we must have the mind of
Christ I'll give you one more go to 2
Corinthians 5:
211 oh very
good
uhuh ah that we might become the so we
are to have the Holiness of God
the righteousness of God partake in the
nature of God and have the mind of you
tell me you have those four things can
God create perfect Holiness in you
yes the problem is we don't
believe let me discuss belief for a
couple
minutes let me stand
up have you ever been to the
dentist have you you ever been to the
dentist yes when you walked into the
office what happened to your
body
huh when he told you sit in the chair
what's what happened on the inside do
you start to get tense yes or no why
what are you expecting
pain pain and he has done
nothing you
believe you'll suffer
and he tilts you back
flat and you you're waiting for
hell you
believe you believe it affects your
physiology
now do you believe that Christ can
produces do you believe you can do
what's right do you believe that does it
affect your physiology does it affect
your choices is do you
believe the same way you believe the
dentist will make you
suffer we have to believe I can conquer
this
weakness the Bible talks about God who
calleth those things which be not as
though they are you know what he said of
Jeremiah Jeremiah verse one verse 5
chapter 1 verse 5 before I formed the in
the belly
I knew thee God saw Jeremiah before
Jeremiah was
conceived before God said let there be
light he knew what he had in
mind you can't surprise God when God
said let the let the Earth bring forth
grass God already saw what grass would
look
like can you see what a successful
student looks like even before you take
your exam
can you see what a calm person is like
even though right now you have a
temper can you see a calm person who has
your
name if you see it it'll come
out perfecting
Holiness yes not in your own power in
the power of Christ as you remain always
submitted and always in his words
studying and obeying
this will produce the Holiness that God
requires I said this morning or was it
last night when God said let us make man
in our image that standard Still
Remains
okay thank you uh this question is is
the holy spirit a a third person is it
wrong to be anti-trinitarian is what
this person
asked is it wrong to be anti
antitrinitarian that means it wrong to
oppose the biblical concept of the
Trinity the answer is yes go to Matthew
12 quickly please let me pray again
father I'm about to comment on a
controversial subject that is really
quite clear in the Bible give me the
right words de God break down the
Jericho walls of stubbornness that
surround anyone's mind regarding this
subject in Jesus name I pray amen go uh
Matthew 12 someone read verse 31 for me
and verse
32 ah I have a a good sister stand up
read for us therefore I say now listen
very
carefully therefore I say unto you all
manner
of
yes the blasphemy against whom spirit
all right the holy spirit will not be
forgiven now the Jesus said says
blasphemy against the holy spirit is not
forgiven that's what Jesus said read the
next verse
stop anyone who speaks a word against
the son of man who is the son of man
Jesus he himself says you can speak
against
me and be
forgiven are you looking in your Bible
Bibles what does he going on to say in
verse
what
yes all right now in verses 31 and
32 are the two beings who are the
targets of blasphemy who are the two
Jesus and holy spirit Jes Jesus said you
can blaspheme
me are you with me there's forgiveness
you blasphemed the Holy
Ghost there's no forgiveness then what
is Jesus saying about the Holy
Ghost there is come on a holy
ghost now let us go to Luke chapter
4 Luke CH
4 someone read for me verse 18
of Luke chap ah okay yes God bless you
for your eagerness to read God bless you
I'm coming to you I'm coming to
you no Luke 4:
18 go
on the spirit of the Lord go on stop are
the two personalities in the word she
has read who are the
two who's the other one me that's Jesus
the spirit of the Lord is upon me keep
reading because he has he has anointed
me come on preach the gospel stop that's
fine that's fine he hath anointed me you
see Jesus let me stand up
again Jesus could not anoint
himself are you with me yes a priest a
judge a priest a king a prophet did not
anoint
themselves they had to be anointed by
someone
else Biblical teaching Jesus said the
spirit of the Lord is upon me he hath
anointed me to preach the gospel to the
poor now go to the book of Acts chapter
10 right to the front to my left Acts
chapter 10 read verse 38 keep in mind
what Jesus said the spirit of the Lord
is upon me he has anointed me on I'll
come back to you I'll come back to you
acts
10:38 listen
carefully okay how God anointed Jesus of
Nazareth with the Holy Spirit ah how God
anointed Jesus of Nazareth with the H
okay mhm so we know Jesus was anointed
and the instrument the father used was
the Holy Spirit finish the verse for us
and with power who about doing good
who were oppressed by the devil for God
was with yes the father anointed Christ
through the instrument of the spirit the
spirit is the active anointing agent now
someone go to Hebrews chapter
5 Hebrews
5 how about one of my brothers yes read
from verse one Hebrews 5 verse one nice
and clear for every high priest taken
from a
maned from things pertain to notice that
every high priest taken from among men
is ordained for men is ordained not
self-ordained must be ordained by
someone else keep reading who can have
God that he may offer boths and
sacrifices who can compassion on
ignor out of the way himself also comp
go on and by reason reason he ought as
for the
also for himself to offer now pause
listen to verse four read on and no man
take this honor unto himself stop but he
stop stop stop don't sit just stop no
man taketh this honor now what office
are we
discussing the high priest verse four
says no one takes it onto
himself you don't go and apply to be
high
priest you're chosen by
God no man taketh this honor unto
himself keep reading but he that is as
was yes someone else called Aaron Aaron
didn't call himself now Aaron was a high
priest representing whom Jesus Christ
now is Christ high priest now yes or no
did he anoint himself no who did the
father through the spirit keep reading
verse five so also glorified not himself
yes made yes stop Christ did not make
himself a high
priest when Moses anointed uh Aaron as
high priest what did Moses
use oil the oil represents the
spirit God use the Holy Ghost to anoint
Jesus as
priest Jesus on the Earth by the
anointing of the Holy Spirit Christ
could not make himself
priest somewh else had to anoint
him the anointing power the Holy Spirit
the anointing Authority the
father are you following me the
anointing now if United States goes to
war The Authority is Congress the power
the soldiers that the Abram tank or the
F16 whatever are you following me the
authority Congress or the president the
power the military force the authority
the Father the power the Holy Spirit
anointed
Christ so there must be someone more
than Christ you see now let's go to
Matthew
3 matth no no let's not go to Matthew 3
let's go to John 13 I see my sister in
the green
I think that's
green Matthew 13 let's read from verse
16 Matthew 1 not Matthew John 13 thank
you for
listening John 13 read no okay I'll come
to you but my sister here first yeah
I'll come to you I'll come to you please
don't cry I'll come to you all
right John 13 reading from verse 16
listen
carefully I tell you what just turn
around ah Now read to the
people hold on hold
on okay most assuredly I say to you a
servant is not greater than his master
nor is he who is sent greater than he
who sent him that's that's fine that's
fine
now a servant is not greater than his
master or his Lord neither he that is
sent greater than him that come on sent
him now he that is sent he that sent him
who's
greater come on speak with confidence
even when you're wrong are you with me
all right now let's try that again he
that is sent and he that sent him who
has greater Authority the one who
sends listen to this verse and this is
life eternal that they might Know Thee
the Know Thee the only to God and Jesus
Christ whom thou has sent who sent
Christ who has great
Authority now are they two persons yes
the father sent the
son now go to John 14 uh my sister over
here okay John 14 read verse
26 of John 14 you know the Bible is the
most interesting book if you take time
to study
am oh thank you John 14:26 listen
carefully okay oh oh thank you it says
but the helper the Holy Spirit whom the
father will send in my name he will
teach you all things and bring to your
remembrance all things that I said to
you all right now it says but the
comforter which is the Holy Ghost whom
the father will send in my
name who sends the Holy Ghost
based on that
verse the
father but in whose
name
yes now go to John 15 Read verse 26 who
will use the mic ah all right John 15
verse 26 well ladies first but since
you're handsome you go ahead go ahead go
ahead John 15:26 listen
carefully but when the helper comes whom
I shall send to you ah wait a minute who
now in verse 26 of chapter 15 sends the
Holy Ghost called the
helper
Jesus read the whole
verse um from the Father the spirit of
Truth who proceeds from the father he
will testify of me good thank you in
math in John 14:26 the father sends the
spirit in John 15:26 Jesus sends the
spirit now we already have the principle
in John 13:16 the one who sends is
greater than the one sent
are you with me yes then the father can
send the
spirit the son can send the
spirit there's no verse in the Bible
where the spirit has ever sent the
father
anywhere and the spirit only directed
Christ when Christ was in
his
Humanity but in his divinity the spirit
gives him no
directions he he was the one who sent
the spirit with the gift of
tongues when he ascended are you
following me what am I trying to say we
have father we have son we have Holy
Ghost go to acts not acts 1 Corinthians
2 who needs a
mic 1 Corinthians 2 oh here you go my
lovely sister someone read verse
10 well 9 and 10 what time is it 5 to
5 do you have when does the sun
set7 507 oh really all right uh I said 1
Corinthians 2 9 and 10 who's reading
okay my sister right oh okay someone has
preempt I'll come back to you I'll come
back please don't cry I'll come back go
ahead go ahead stand up all right turn
around reforce now
but as it is written I Has Not Seen Nor
Ear heard nor have entered into the
heart of man the things which God has
prepared for those who love him but God
has revealed them to us through his
Spirit pause God has an agent that
serves God the spirit he reveals the
things of God to us keep reading for the
spirit searches all things yes the Deep
things of God ah no the word search
means understands can explain the spirit
searches understands
what look at the
verse the Deep not the shallow things of
God the Deep things of God but prior to
that we learn the spirit searcheth all
things what are the all things all the
Deep things of God the spirit
understands
any being who understands everything
about God must himself be
God now read verse
oh verse 11 of 1 Corinthians
2 for what man knows the things of man
except the spirit of the man which is
uhhuh MHM go on even so no no one knows
the things of God except the spirit of
God yes whatever God knows the Holy
Spirit
knows then the Holy Spirit must be as
Divine as God is even though he has
different
responsibilities now go to Matthew 11
read verse
27 okay okay
right all right here
oh okay stand up turn around and read
for us Matthew
11:27 all things have been delivered to
me by my father and no one knows the son
except the father nor does anyone know
the father except the son the one whom
and the one to whom the son will Wills
to reveal him yes now what is Jesus
saying I know the
father and the father knows me as much
as the father knows me me I know the
Father which means that the same way the
Holy Ghost knows everything the father
knows so they're equally Divine
everything the Father Knows Jesus knows
they equally Divine but they have
different
responsibilities and so the father can
send the spirit the father sends
Jesus Jesus does not send the father
anywhere the Holy Ghost does not send
the father any anywhere and in his
divinity the Holy Ghost does not send
Christ anywhere the spirit directed
Christ in his
Humanity when you have time go to the
book evangelism read the chapter
entitled Mis representations of the
godhead Ellen White you will see where
she clearly states the Holy Ghost is a
person as much as the other members of
the godhead are persons and finally at
the baptism of Jesus Christ and Jesus
when he was baptized went up straight
away out of the water where was
Christ in the
water and lo the heavens were open unto
him and he saw the spirit of God
descending like a dove and Lighting on
him Jesus looking up to heaven he sees
something a apart from
himself the spirit of God descending
like a
dove enlightening on him so we have
Jesus in the water the spirit coming
down from the heavens and law of voice
from heaven now we have three locations
a voice from Heaven A being coming to
the skies and Christ in the
water one person can't be at the same
place three places at the same same
time there's an ancient era that says
Christ expresses himself as father son
Holy Ghost but the one person one person
can't be in heaven the skies and in the
water at the same
time Christ was in the baptismal water
just coming out the Bible says he
saw the spirit of God
descending Christ was coming up that's
what the Bible says out of the water the
Holy Spirit was coming
down two different
directions and a voice in heaven this is
my beloved Son in whom I am well pleased
listen to me carefully with no
disrespect to those who do not believe
there's a holy spirit or the word
Trinity is causes a problem the Trinity
has suggested one person in three
different forms no it is three
separate individual
personalities but one
substance and we have a clue to help us
understand that Genesis 2:4 therefore
shall a man leave his father and his
mother and shall cleave to his wife and
they too shall be one
flesh if a man and a woman can be one
why can't father son and spirit be one
can you explain that to me why not if a
man man a woman and a child can be one
family why can't father son and spirit
be one Heavenly
family are you with me if you have to
doubt somebody don't doubt the Holy
Ghost because Jesus tells you if you
blaspheme him there's no
forgiveness and so to say there's no
Holy Ghost is to place yourself in
Mortal
danger and you worsen your condition by
trying to get others to believe there's
no Holy
Ghost if you have to go to hell go by
yourself don't evangelize others into
hell with you go by
yourself please young
people the Holy
Ghost is your friend
your guide your convicting power your
restraining power he's the one who opens
the mind you can understand the word of
God and he's the one who runs the
work Christ said I will pray to the
Father John 14:16 and he shall give you
another comforter we have three I will
pray to the father two he shall give you
another meaning you see Christ was the
first comforter the father will send
another so it cannot be
Christ another means different
from if I had one apple and I said give
me another you don't tell me well you
just had eat the one you just ate mm- I
need another one a separate one a second
one I will give you another or he will
give you another
comforter so the father gives the
comforter at the prayer of Jesus
Christ there is a holy
ghost there's the
son there's the
father in Divinity they're this
way in duties and
responsibilities they're this
way are you with me look at a family the
father is a family member the mother is
a family member the child is a family
member one 100% in duties and
responsibility and Authority we have the
father according to the biblical model
the mother and the child but in
substance father mother child in
function responsibility father mother
child in substance God the Father God
the son God the Holy Ghost in duties and
responsibilities God the Father God the
son God the Holy
Ghost all right
may I just step up
here okay we've got a handful left um
all right I've kind of there's been a
few questions that are duplicat so we've
set those aside or if they're very very
similar and you've already touched on on
the principles so this person asks and
you did talk a little bit about this
during one of your messages what do you
think about relationships in high school
relationships in high school are fine if
it's with your book
your textbook ah yes please your parents
let me get up again
your your parents did not send you here
to get
engaged they sent you to get an
education are you with me now can you
have friendships yes but as I told you
earlier God put a man and a woman
together not a boy and a girl a boy and
a girl are not emotionally mature enough
to make to handle that thing in a way
that honors
God there are too many boys and girls
who have boyfriends and girlfriends and
uh H romance is for
adults um young adults yes when you're
13 and 14 and 15 you're not a young
adult you're a teenager you're
child if you behave like an adult
someone may treat you like an adult in
the wrong way are you following
me let
me your childhood is short are you with
me your adulthood is long everything
don't rush
this to go pay
taxes are you following me don't rush
this it passes is
quickly and then you have 50 years
of responsibilities and bills and
whatever else in
even be a child if you are child now
that's what you
are don't be a child trying to behave
like an
adult be a responsible child
yes but
don't focus on Romance
when you were sent for
education and so that's all I'll say to
you it's a very serious matter getting
involved with people's
feelings you may be doing the service
not only to her but to her family who
thinks that she has come to carry out
the reason why she was sent and quietly
there's some young
man corrupting a thinking or some young
lady corrupting his thinking it goes
both
ways you are are not yet
emotionally mature let me tell you
something about
maturity you won't like this but it's
scientific if you don't believe me go on
do a research with the permission of
your your teachers research the
Adolescent
brain are you following me read some
articles about the Adolescent brain
you'll discover the last organ of the
body to develop is the
brain the last one to fully develop is
the brain and the experts say somewhere
between your 25 27 28 somewhere in there
it fully develops it develops from the
back to the
front are you following me it develops
from the back to the front so the last
part of the brain to develop is the
frontal lobe where what is made
decisions and
choices so you have a 14-year-old boy
who can be a
father with a brain that's not yet
developed he needs
supervision listen to me young people
are not
bad they're just not yet
mature let me tell you something else as
I step
down do you know why insurance rates are
higher for
teenagers
recklessness now that recklessness isn't
vicious that person has not yet
developed the ability to determine
risk statistics have shown if a teenager
is driving a car there's a 50% chance
he'll have an
accident if another teenager gets into
the car with him there's a 60% chance
he'll have an accident if another
teenager gets in there's a 70% chance if
a third teenager enters there's an 80
this has been
studied why because all four of them
[Laughter]
have now am I saying you can't say yes
you can think of
course but
developmentally you're not yet at the
point so you need
guidance
supervision Godly
guidance Godly
supervision you can't send a 70y old boy
and a 16y old girl to to to get Bible
studies you're asking for
trouble they're nice they read the Bible
they're vegetarians but this thing is
still
developing and so
romance that requires good
thinking to avoid emotional damage and
long-term
harm ah you need a mind that's ready for
that but we live in a world where
everything on TV is some young man and
some young
girl and they're not studying the
Bible and so no I don't recommend
romance to be a focus
no that's just my
recommendation chances are you're not
ready now there's nothing wrong with
relationships God invented them but as I
said again he put a man and a woman not
a boy and a
girl do you still like me a little
bit next question my pastor I'll stay
right here oh yes give me the
word next
question all right the next question
is um as a Christian how do I act
towards people who are hypocrites or
fake okay
well that person just described all of
us to some
degree except for the grace of
Christ anyone outside of
Christ fits that
description all have sinned and come
short of the glory of God that's what
the Bible says we all need Christ we all
need Grace we all need help again I
point you to the character of Christ
study the character of Christ how how do
I deal with those who are fake and
what's the other word hypocritical
hypocritical Christ came to a world full
of people who were fake and
hypocritical there's none righteous no
not one he came to a world of fake and
hypocritical people and he was tolerant
to them he didn't tolerate the hypocrisy
he tolerated them as weak people on the
cross he said father forgive them for
they know not what they do he understood
their
weaknesses if you have to deal with
someone you assess to be fake and
hypocritical you deal with them the way
Christ would deal you don't have to
spread their fakeness spread their
hypocrisy but you remember I too was in
that condition when the Israelites left
Egypt they got instructions from God
treat your slaves nicely because you
were a
slave and so we see a hypoc hypocritical
person has an opportunity to pray for
that person and by your own example lead
that person to the level of sincerity
and truthfulness in his or her life but
certainly don't look down your nose and
assume you're better
than you're an instrument in Christ's
hands to reach out to that person but
you will run into fake people and God
allows that sometimes to test your
character test your character how will
you react
will that fake person see the real thing
in
you okay next question right uh this
person is asking is it okay for someone
who is in the military or in a medical
Prof uh profession to work on Sabbath
and if so should the money earned go
towards the mission of the church we
must do everything we can to avoid
working on Sabbath when I say we I mean
every human being who respects God's law
doctor nurse dentist you name it we must
do every everything possible to avoid
Sabbath work but Jesus says it's lawful
to do good on the Sabbath and so he
healed a man who had I believe the
dropsy in I think it's Luke 14 or
Matthew something he healed that man man
with a withed arm healed him on the
Sabbath doing good on the Sabbath is not
working on the Sabbath Jesus never said
it's lawful to work on the Sabbath he
said it's lawful to do
good your animal falls into a pit pull
it out on the Sabbath God is not a
promoter of
suffering if as a medical doctor a nurse
some such field you have to go in El
counsels us medical Ministry page 216
paragraph 2 do what is necessary to
relieve
suffering and give the money earned to
the
church because you're not supposed to
earn a living on the
Sabbath now some of us we cleverly say
well I'm a nurse I go to work because
the pay on Saturday is
[Music]
double maybe twice and a half maybe
triple and so some of us under the guise
of I'm a nurse I'm a doctor I can go to
work knowing they're going for the
money not so much to relieve suffering I
get double pay triple I can provide
tuition for my
child God reads this
do everything in your power not to work
listen to the Commandment remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy six days
shalt thou labor and do all thy work but
the seventh day is the Sabbath of the
Lord thy God in it what are the next few
words Thou shalt not
[Music]
do but if you must go in go to relieve
suffering whatever compensation given to
you give it to the church
don't keep it the moment you make an
exception for one commandment you've
opened the door to make exceptions for
another
one now we can't start that once that
horse gets out of the barn you can't put
it back
in do not make exceptions regarding
God's law because someone will come up
with an exception for Thou shalt not
commit
adultery the sinful mind is clever in
developing ways to get around God's law
very
clever it is simply a method of suicide
that's all it is getting around God's
law because disobedience is
death but a sinful mind doesn't see
that obey God as much as you can obey
God and leave the consequences to him
next question this person asks how can I
stop being selfish and prideful look at
Calvary look at Calvary start with John
3:16 for God so loved the world that he
gave the love of God is self
sacrificing I say it again the love of
God is self sacrificing study that
you'll be cured of
selfishness okay last question second
last question how do you overcome the
fear of public speaking
speak I'm serious no just speak let me
ask you this if someone were to say to
you listen you know whatever name is
John Sally Nebuchadnezzar whatever your
name is someone says to you would you
tell us about your family where you from
how many brothers how many sisters you
know where you would stand up and do
it because you'd be talking about
something you
know you understand me when you know
something it moves a lot of the fear of
public speaking when God called go to
Jeremiah chapter 1 Jeremiah 1 let's read
from verse 5 do you have Jeremiah 1
reading verse
5 no one has Jeremiah yet ah you haven't
all right stand up for us read from
verse 5 nice and Loud I've got it I've
got it I've got it okay hold on hold on
hold on read
567 before I form you in the womb I knew
you before you were born i s sanctifies
you I ORD you a prophet to the Nations
now listen to the next verse then said I
then said I said then said I our Lord
God behold I cannot speak stop stop I
can't
speak keep reading for for I am a Jo mhm
I'm a child I can't speak what did God
say but the Lord said to me do not say
I'm a y stop mhm don't say that thank
you sister do not say that unless you
can prove to me says God you do not have
a voice
box you can speak Jeremiah said I can't
speak I'm a
child I am at Mountain View Academy a
Blue Mountain Academy I am a
child God says don't say
that because if I send you I'll enable
you
now go to Exodus chapter 4 let's read
from verse 10 God calls Moses now to go
speak to Pharaoh yes Exodus chapter 4
let's read from verse 10 did you raise
your hand oh I'm so sorry I have sinned
I have sinned all right who raised the
hand ah okay here we go read for us my
lovely sister verse 10 10 to 12 okay
listen carefully then Moses said to the
Lord oh my Lord I am not eloquent
neither before for nor since you have
spoken to your servant but I am slow of
speech and slow of tongue pause Moses
said I am slow of speech I must
apologize to the camera person I keep
moving I am slow of speech of a slow
tongue he had forgotten how to speak
Egyptian he' been gone so long so he
tells God I can't do this I can't speak
keep
reading so the Lord said to him who has
made man's mouth or stop when you speak
what do you use
yeah God tell Moses wait a minute you
have a problem with your mouth do you
know who made the
mouth if you have a problem with it I
can fix it keep
reading who ha made man's mouth or who
maketh the dumb or the deaf okay the
seeing or the blind have not I the Lord
now there now therefore go and I will be
with your mouth and teach you what you
shall say thank you God told Moses don't
bring excuses to me I made your mouth
you got a problem with it I'll fix it
you go I will teach you what to say
listen to me anytime you're asked to
speak say yes
am regard it as a request from God
through that person the principal says
would you do a 10-minute uh devotion say
yes the more you do it the better you do
it it I'm not saying you lose all
nervousness no but you'll be better at
expressing yourself God the greatest
gift God has given to us is speech am
mhm use it final question the final
question is when can we get you to come
back
oh oh well talk to God about that okay
okay well God bless you as as as the
Sabbath has ended we're just wondering
well first of all we just want to thank
you again priv for traveling the way
from across the world to be here with us
and we praise God for what he's done
through you so again as we prayed for
you earlier I just want to say a quick
prayer for you now and um if you will be
able to end in prayer to close the
Sabbath Father in heaven we thank you so
much for your servant Elder Randy SK
thank you Lord for using him in so many
different ways uh for helping him answer
uh some of the questions that we have
been asking and Lord I just pray Lord as
we U meditate on these things that as
he's reminded us um we are not to go to
human minds but to go to the word and
Lord may we continue to search your word
as we behold it Lord we know that we
will become changed so Lord we just pray
that you give him traveling mercies as I
know he's going to Zimbabwe I believe
next week we just pray that uh your
angels would be uh tapping the right
people on on the shoulder that should be
there for these meetings that Lord they
would be there to listen to for the
message at such a time as this so Lord
give him traveling mercies as he flies
out tomorrow uh may you go with him in a
special way in Jesus name and everyone
said amen all right just a few closing
remarks then I'm done let's recite the
fourth
Commandment Exodus 20 8-11 King James
version remember the Sabbath day to keep
it holy six days sh thou labor and do
all thy work but the seventh day is the
Sabbath of the Lord thy God in it Thou
shalt not do any work thou nor thy son
nor thy daughter thy man's servant nor
thy maid servant nor thy cattle nor thy
stranger that is within thy gates for in
six days the Lord made Heaven and Earth
the sea and all that in them is and
rested the seventh day wherefore the
Lord blessed the Sabbath day and
hallowed it now God tells us keep the
Sabbath
holy have you ever been to a
museum if you ever go to Paris go to the
L and see those famous
paintings the the the museum keeps them
holy the museum protects them the museum
Treasures them the museum understands
their value and so they do everything to
keep them safe God tells us here is the
only day I made
holy now here it
is take care of it for
me keep it
holy handle it with care it's it's
precious to me it's the only one that
that that uh tells you who I am the area
of my
influence and what I did my title who I
am
Creator my influence Heaven and Earth my
name
God and God says I am asking you to take
care of this precious thing for
me I'm not ask asking you to make it
holy you can't do that I'm asking you
preserve its Holiness by your speaking
your thinking and your
behaving take care of it for me this is
an act of
trust I'm going overseas for two weeks I
have a Lamborghini would you take care
of it for me
yes huh you won't treat it like your
forward Focus are you following me this
is a
Lamborghini take care of it if a fly
rests on it you shoot a fly
off God says here's my
Sabbath take care of it how many of you
will say
father by your grace I'll try to take
care of your Sabbath day can I see your
ah God bless you stand up with me stand
up with me before I
pray any prayer requests
just raise your hand and tell me
yes wisdom and understanding james: 15
wisdom yes and management grades and
time management I aspire to be a physan
you want to be a physician okay Luke was
a physician Colossians chapter
4:14 okay your father's faith
discernment for him okay discernment for
him my family your family my life your
what your spiritual
life make oh yes wise decisions
yes my character
your your what character oh yes yes yes
for my nonel mother your non-believing
mother ah okay for my health and for my
arm your health and for your AR arm
what's wrong with your arm
okay okay okay
yes my family your family
and
determination oh oh determination yes
yes yes yes okay
yes your who my grandmother your
grandmother okay my unbelieving brother
your unbelieving brother uh for our
friend's he your
what health health oh friends health
okay I'm coming over
yes
okay your friend my brother your brother
my studies your
studies my brother your
brother your who your
grandfather future plans and patience of
Love patience of love yes my mother your
mother
yes
who your family my dad's your my dad's
your dad's work my unbelieving father
your unbelieving
father your
mother unbel family unbelieving
family H wisdom and
self-control yes Father your father
leadership leadership leadership
leadership
okay students thinking about
baptism students thinking who's
considering baptism can I see your hand
come come quickly special prayer come
come come come you considering baptism
come and if someone will make a decision
right now you come amen right now come
God will pray especially for you mm God
is happy you're considering baptism come
come come come yeah come come come come
God bless you God bless God needs young
people the devil has so many of them he
needs them you know the Bible says
remember now thy Creator in the days of
thy youth but Satan also wants you when
you're young if he can get you now
chances are he'll keep you if God can
get you now chances are he'll keep it
anyone else considering baptism come
come come sister
come just let God see that's how you're
thinking anybody else you're considering
it come just come quickly then I'll
pray anybody else considering
it
okay heads bowed eyes
closed dear father in
Heaven I thank you personally for a
glorious weekend with your sons and your
daughters at Blue Mountain Academy and
the
administrators father if in any way I
did not represent you well forgive
me I present to you now the young men
the young women and all the concerns for
family for health education
self-improvement leadership
self-control parents grandparents
unbelieving de God the angel Gabriel
told Mary in Luke
137 for with God nothing shall be
impossible you told Abraham in Genesis
18:14 is anything too hard for the the
Lord you can bring those unbelieving
family members to Christ you can heal
that dislocated arm you can provide the
self-control you can give the skills for
leadership father whatever the request
is they go it is not beyond your
power and so we ask you now in the name
of Jesus Christ who is human as we are
human who represents Us in his name
father begin working in the lives of
those who made those requests known now
God
these young men these young women are
considering baptism you are pleased
again in the name of Jesus Christ who
himself was baptized let them only
become stronger in this decision and
this determination let no power friends
family or anything else change their
minds bless them again I ask you to
bless this institution father bless the
conference in which it sits bless the
leadership let the words heard this
weekend long remain in the hearts of
your people save us when you come father
until then keep us faithful unto death
in Jesus name I pray let God's people
say amen and amen I love you God bless
you if I don't see you again I hope
we'll meet when Jesus comes and he is
coming